Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ein neues Jahr, ein neuer Tag, eine neue Ausgabe, Logbuch Netzpolitik, Linus.
Tim.
Bist noch ganz verwirrt, ne?
Ja, ich wusste jetzt nicht genau, wie wir jetzt weitermachen. Du hast ja, also weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Das weiß man auch immer vorher nicht, sondern man muss das Ganze auch flexibilisieren und mal ein wenig auf sich zukommen lassen. Ja genau, dem Zufall eine Rolle geben.
Kannst du mir mal hier ein Kabel geben?
Ja, kann ich machen. Was fällst du denn gerne, so ein Legacy-Kabel?
Nee, nichts legacy. Ich nehme auch jetzt hier bei den Coolen.
Bitteschön. Während Linus sich sozusagen noch das Kabel in den Kopf steckt, um genug Saft zu haben, begrüße ich alle hier herzlich in unserem, na ja, man kann jetzt davon reden, sozusagen unserer zweiten Saison. Also rein faktisch hat die natürlich schon etwas früher angefangen.
Wir gehen in das dritte Jahr.
Ja. Das ist jetzt etwas überheblich, finde ich.
2011 angefangen.
Na ja, das ist geschummelt. Wir schummeln ja hier nicht. Wir sind ja nicht nur neutral und unaufgeregt, sondern wir schummeln ja auch nicht.
Ich bin seit 2011 Podcaster.
Du bist ja auch in der Liste der sexy Podcaster aufgenommen. Da kannst du ja alles rausnehmen.
Ich bin in der Liste der sexy Podcaster.
Na ja, da gehöre ich zwar nicht dazu, aber dafür umringe ich mich einfach mit solchen Menschen. So, was haben wir denn noch in der Hinterhand, Linus?
Kirsten haben wir in der Hinterhand.
Ja, genau.
Kirsten Fiedler. Genau, zugeschaltet aus Brüssel. Vielen sicherlich bekannt durch ihren Podcast NetPolitik, NPEU, der Gratis-Podcast on EU-Polices in the Digital Era.
Genau, Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete.
Haben wir das schon berichtet?
Ich glaube, das haben wir schon mal eingeworfen.
Ich bin gar nicht so sicher, ob wir das schon eingeworfen haben.
Na wenn nicht, dann betonen wir das jetzt einfach.
Tun wir jetzt einfach. Und sie ist Lobbyistin für European Digital Rights, nennt sich aber nicht Lobbyistin, sondern Advocacy Manager.
Fürsprecherin.
Fürsprecherin. Das ist ein schöneres Wort für Lobbyistin. European Digital Rights, ein Zusammenschluss von wie vielen NGOs, Kirsten?
Von 32 Datenschutz- und Bürgerrechtsorganisationen. Ich glaube, aus insgesamt 20 europäischen Ländern.
Wie viele sind davon aus Deutschland?
Oh Gott, keine Ahnung, ziemlich viele. Also der FÖBUD, ne Moment, wie heißt es? Digital-Kourage, Digitale Gesellschaft, der CCC ist dabei und noch ein paar mehr.
Aber auch Österreich, auch Schweiz und überhaupt auch sonst alle großen Länder Europas sind vertreten?
Genau, ja. Also aus England die Open Rights Group ist noch mit dabei, aus den Niederlanden kennt man vielleicht Bits of Freedom.
Eigentlich alles, was Rang und Namen hat.
Ja und idri gibt es ja auch, ist ja jetzt auch keine neue Erfindung, sondern idri wirkt schon seit längerem, gefühlt sind es mindestens 6, 7, 8 Jahre. Kann das hinhauen oder ist es sogar noch ein bisschen mehr?
Ja, wir feiern dieses Jahr unseren zehnten Geburtstag. Das machen wir in zwei Monaten hier in Brüssel mit einer großen Party.
Ah und wer ist alles eingeladen?
Ja, könnt gerne vorbeikommen.
Sind alle eingeladen sozusagen? Ahja.
Aus Deutschland noch FIF, das Forum der Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung und FITUK natürlich, wofür Förderverein Informationstechnik und Gesellschaft. Nur damit wir da jetzt keinen beleidigen oder so.
Danke Linus. Alle komplizierten Abkürzungen der 80er Jahre enthalten. Ja, warum haben wir dich eingeladen? Erstens, weil das sowieso angemessen ist. Zweitens hast du ja auch auf dem Kongress, dem 29. Chaos Communication Kongress, der ja kürzlich in Hamburg stattfand, einen Panel mitbekleidet.
Das Panel haben wir mit Kasia aus Polen von der Panopticon Foundation und Jan Philipp Albrecht dem Europa-Abgeordneten gemacht. Und zwar ging es da um die Datenschutzreform, die gerade hier in Europa läuft und die gerade überall in den Medien ist.
Und um die ihr euch als Advoxie-Manager in Brüssel kümmert.
Genau, also Datenschutz ist ja Grundrecht und von daher fällt das in unseren Aktivitätenbereich.
Du warst außerdem, Jan Philipp Albrecht war auch noch da auf dem Panel, oder?
Genau.
Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche. Der ist Europaparlament-Abgeordneter für die Grünen. Und der hat die Funktion des Berichterstatter zu diesem Thema, ne?
Ja, also vielleicht, um mal alles zu erklären, von vorne angefangen, vor einem Jahr hat die Justizkommissarin Vivian Redding die große Datenschutzreform gestartet. Und die derzeitigen Regeln sind halt noch von 1995. Also war es höchste Zeit, dass das mal ein Update gemacht wird. Und genau das hat jetzt die Kommission mit zwei Vorschlägen gemacht. Also die hat im Januar 2012 die allgemeine Datenschutzverordnung für den privaten Sektor und eine Richtlinie für Polizei und Justiz vorgeschlagen. Genau. Und das war vor einem Jahr. Und jetzt geht das Ding quasi durch das Europaparlament. Und der Hauptzuständige, Europaabgeordnete, ist Jan-Philipp Albrecht.
Jetzt ganz kurz, du müsstest wahrscheinlich zwei Sachen erklären. Verordnung, was ist jetzt nochmal der genaue Unterschied zwischen, oder was genau ist die Bedeutung einer Verordnung?
Ja, also die Tagesschau hatte ja vor ein paar Tagen auch das verwechselt irgendwie und hatte von einer Richtlinie gesprochen. Also eine Richtlinie, EU-Richtlinien können umgesetzt werden, wie Mitgliedstaaten das so für richtig halten. Und deswegen gibt es bis jetzt noch keinen harmonisierten Datenschutz in Europa. Und mit der Verordnung wird es überall in Europa einen einheitlichen Standard geben. Also die wird quasi direkt als Gesetz für alle Mitgliedstaaten gelten.
Das heißt, der Begriff Reform trifft eigentlich auch nur sehr begrenzt zu, insofern, als dass das jetzt die erste Verordnung überhaupt ist. Die erste wirklich verbindliche Regelung.
Genau, also vorher galt halt die Richtlinie von 1995 und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass es in Deutschland einen sehr guten Datenschutzstandard gibt und in Irland dafür vielleicht ein bisschen luschi luschi umgesetzt wurde. Genau, Facebook, Google sitzen ja alle in Irland.
Und um diesen Marktvorteil im Binnenmarkt diese Konkurrenz auszumerzen, hat man sich darauf geeinigt, die Datenschutzgesetze anzugleichen? Oder die Frage ist, welchen anderen Grund sehen sie, quasi ein Datenschutzgesetz für die gesamte EU zu machen?
Ja, das wird auf jeden Fall wirtschaftliche Vorteile haben und wir haben ja derzeit das Problem, dass in Deutschland Datenschutz einfach umgangen wird, dadurch, dass Facebook und Google sich in Irland niedergelassen haben.
Auf wessen Initiative ist es denn jetzt überhaupt zu dieser Verordnung gekommen? Also war das so eine allgemeine Einsicht des Parlaments, dass das doch mal an sich eine ganz gute Idee war? Oder ist da irgendjemand vorangeschritten und hat das mal forciert? Wart ihr daran beteiligt?
Also mehrere Faktoren haben dazu geführt. Erstens gibt es seit 2009 den Lissabon-Vertrag. Und durch den Lissabon-Vertrag gelten die Karta für Grundrechte. Und deswegen musste die EU-Kommission jetzt quasi das Datenschutzrecht reformieren. Und zweitens gab es im letzten, also noch bevor die Kommission die Reform gestartet hat, 2011 einen Entwurf vom Europaparlament, einen Beschluss, in dem die Europaparlamentarier die Reform gefordert hatten.
Okay, und was halten wir jetzt erstmal von dieser Reform? Oder was haltet ihr jetzt erstmal von dieser Reform, das ihr gerade schon gesagt habt, es wurde quasi eine formuliert, die jetzt in das Parlament hinuntergereicht wurde. Wie gefällt euch die denn? Also habt ihr jetzt die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen?
Und wer hat die formuliert, würde mich vor allem interessieren?
Wer hat was formuliert?
Diese Verordnung jetzt so, in der Form, wie sie da jetzt ist, wessen Handschrift trägt sie?
Genau, also ja, wie ich schon sagte, vor allem ja hat die Justizkommissarin Vivian Redding die zwei Vorschläge quasi auf den Tisch gelegt. Und jetzt geht das ganze Ding durch das Europaparlament. Also das heißt, einige Ausschüsse im Europaparlament befassen sich damit und geben Stellungnahmen ab. Und die fließen dann alle in den offiziellen Bericht des Europaparlaments ein. Und für diesen Bericht ist halt der grüne Abgeordnete Jan-Philipp Albrecht zuständig. Und der hat jetzt vorgestern diesen offiziellen Bericht vorgelegt. Und ja, also insgesamt gibt es schon ziemlich viele Verbesserungen gegenüber dem Kommissionsentwurf, der damals, also Ende 2011, total heftig durch US-Lobbing einfach verwässert wurde.
Ja, aber also, weiß nicht, vielleicht hätte ich mich nicht richtig ausgedrückt. Also wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen den aktuellen Entwurf anschaut, also welche Sprache spricht der, geht der grundsätzlich in eine Richtung, mit der auch Edri leben kann oder ist das etwas, was schwierig ist?
Also das kann man so allgemein nicht sagen, weil das Ding ist einfach ein super großes Monster. Also die Verordnung an sich, weiß ich nicht, hat glaube ich 120 Seiten, so um den Dreh in den verschiedenen Sprachen. Und der Bericht, den jetzt Jan-Philipp Albrecht vorgelegt hat, der ist 215 Seiten lang. Ja und ich glaube mittlerweile gibt es so an die 1500 Änderungsanträge. Also das Ding ist einfach Hammer groß und das betrifft halt alle möglichen Sachen von Recht auf Vergessen, also diesen digitalen Radiergummi über verschiedene Definitionen, bis hin zu also was überhaupt personenbezogene Daten sind, bis hin zu Privacy. Was ist Privacy bei Design, was ist Privacy by Default und so weiter. Also das ist sehr sehr umfangreich.
Ja, aber 250 Seiten, zwei Tage wirst du ja sicherlich schon alles durchgelesen haben. Nicht so ganz, ne. Aber ich meine, was muss man jetzt davon halten? Also wir haben ja nun noch gar nichts gelesen, oder? Hast du schon irgendwas gesehen davon, Linus?
Ich habe das mal grob überflogen.
Ja, also generell geht das schon in eine ziemlich gute, in die richtige Richtung. Also damals der Kommissionsvorschlag, der war auch schon ganz gut. Aber es gibt halt noch einige Mängel, die dazu führen könnten, dass das ganze Ding eigentlich überflüssig wird. Also gerade bei den Definitionen kann es gut sein, dass wenn da die Gesetzeslücken nicht geschlossen werden, dass einfach das ganze Ding überflüssig wird.
Im Sinne von, dass es so viele Schlupflöcher gibt, dass man es gar nicht anwenden muss, oder was?
Also ich glaube, ihr hattet das in eurem Vortrag beim Kongress auch so genannt, dass letztendlich scheint das sowas ähnlich zu sein wie bei dem Leistungsschutz-Gesetzesentwurf, dass wenn da eine Definition, wenn da ein Begriff benutzt wird, der einfach nicht klar definiert ist, dass damit der gesamte Paragraf, der gesamte Absatz eigentlich wertlos werden kann, wenn da eine Definition nicht stimmt. Das scheint glaube ich euer Problem an der Stelle zu sein. Nicht, dass der Inhalt des Absatzes blöd ist, sondern dass die Definitionen so unscharf sind, dass sich die Gefahr bietet, dass da irgendwie nichts runterfällt oder alles runterfällt, je nachdem, was einem, was dem Akteur lieber ist.
Genau, es gibt schon so ein paar Lücken, die einfach das Grundrecht auf Datenschutz und Schutz auf Privatsphäre wirklich ernsthaft untergeben können. Also ein Beispiel, das haben wir schon während unseres Vortrags auf der 29c3 erklärt, ist dieser Begriff des berechtigten Interesses. Und es kann gut sein, also wenn es ganz schlimm kommt, kann die Verordnung durch dieses berechtigte Interesse sogar ein Warnhinweismodell gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen einführen. Also einer der sechs Gründe, auf deren Basis personenbezogene Daten verarbeitet werden dürfen, ist das berechtigte Interesse des Datenverarbeiters. Und wie das in der Verordnung vorgeschlagen wurde, kann dieses berechtigte Interesse einfach alles oder nichts heißen. Und weiteres Problem ist, dass wir als Bürger nur Beschwerde bei der Datenschutzbehörde einlegen können. Und anders können wir uns gegen die Verarbeitung unserer Daten aufgrund des berechtigten Interesses nicht wehren. Ja, also wir können Beschwerde bei der Datenschutzbehörde einlegen. Und dieser Begriff berechtigtes Interesse, den gibt es schon seit 1995 und hat schon zu allen möglichen Wahnsinnen geführt. Also ein Beispiel ist in Irland. Die Unterhaltungsindustrie hat dort erfolgreich ein freiwilliges Warnhinweismodell gegen Urheberrechtsverletzungen durchgesetzt. Und zwar sammelt die Musikindustrie da ohne Zustimmung der betroffenen personenbezogene Daten, die dann an den Internetprovider Aircom übermittelt werden, erneut ohne Zustimmung der betroffenen Personen und dann von Aircom weiterverarbeitet werden, um dann verdächtige Nutzer abzumahnen.
Und die Argumentation dafür, das zu tun ist, wir hätten ja ein berechtigtes Interesse daran.
Genau, also das Ganze ist dann vor das höchste Gericht in Irland gegangen und das Gericht hat entschieden, dass es fraglos im berechtigten Interesse von Aircom ist, die Gesetze zu wahren und auch so wahrgenommen zu werden.
Okay, also das ist so eine Vischiwaschi-Formulierung, die im Prinzip dann nichts mehr genauer fassen lässt. Was ist denn so aus eurem Blickwinkel, sind denn so die wichtigsten Aspekte, die ihr gerne in dieser Verordnung umgesetzt sehen möchtet, so als Grundsätze? Und vielleicht kannst du noch mal dazu sagen, wie das so in einem derzeitigen Entwurf in der Richtung dann auch aussieht?
Also, was jetzt direkt diesen Begriff des berechtigten Interesses angeht, den würden wir am liebsten ganz raus haben. Da hat Jan-Philipp Albrecht im Bericht vorgeschlagen, dass das nur in bestimmten Fällen gelten soll und hat ein paar Ausnahmen gelistet. Das würden wir am liebsten ganz raus haben, weil das einfach krass ist. Dann, was wir gerne drin haben wollen, ist ein Artikel, der damals vor einem Jahr durch US-Lobbing rausgenommen wurde, wieder von der EU-Kommission. Das ist ein Artikel, der Zugriff auf Daten durch Drittstaaten regelt. Das heißt, wir wollen, dass EU-Bürger gegen Zugriffe von Drittstaaten geschützt werden. Der Patriot Act und der FISA Act in den USA erlauben es im Moment US-Unternehmen einfach auf unsere Daten zuzugreifen. Die Verordnung kann das verhindern. Also, EU-Datenschutz gilt dann, sobald Daten von EU-Bürgern verarbeitet werden.
Das war, glaube ich, interessanterweise gestern auch Thema bei Spiegel Online, wo da ein großer Artikel zugeschrieben wurde. Ich hielt das eher noch so für einen Teil der großen Kampagne zur Rettung der Cloud-Anbieter in Deutschland. Aber okay, interessant, dass das tatsächlich durch diese EU-Datenschutzrichtlinie auch noch abgewendet werden könnte. Das interessiert mich natürlich schon.
Genau, vielleicht noch zur Erklärung. Im Dezember 2011 gab es halt den ersten internen Entwurf in der EU-Kommission. Und damals hatte das US-Handelsministerium in den Dienststellen der Kommission angerufen und kurz vor der Deadline für interne Kommentare so ein paar Sachen rausgelobbiert. Also die haben da einfach angerufen und gesagt, hier das und das gefällt uns nicht. Und das noch bevor überhaupt der Entwurf offiziell vorgelegt wurde. Und komischerweise gab das damals keinen Skandal. Und ja, also ich würde echt gerne mal sehen, wie das umgekehrt wäre, wenn Europa irgendwie in den USA anrufen würde und versuchen würde, irgendwie Gesetzesentwürfe umschreiben zu lassen, noch bevor das überhaupt alles publik ist.
Ja, das ist der kurze Dienstweg, der ist da glaube ich doch noch sehr verbreitet.
So, das heißt insgesamt sieht es erstmal ganz gut aus. Man muss jetzt nur noch gucken, dass man das Kind auch wirklich in trockene Tücher wickelt.
Genau, und das Problem, das wir im Moment haben, ist, dass hier in Brüssel wirklich eine krasse Lobby gefahren wird von Industrie. Also nicht nur Google und Facebook sind aktiv, sondern wirklich alle Unternehmen in allen Industriebereichen haben hier mindestens einen Lobbyist, der an dem ganzen Dossier arbeitet. Und es gibt halt viele verrückte Vorschläge, die von den Abgeordneten dann einfach so übernommen werden. Also das gilt nicht für die ganze Industrie, macht nicht böse Vorschläge, sondern also so für Allgemeinheit kann man das nicht sagen, aber das sind hauptsächlich halt Google, Facebook, Kreditinstitute oder Direktmarketing, die da ziemlich komische Sachen vorschlagen.
Also vor allem die, die im Wesentlichen von den Kunden Daten auch leben.
Also um mal ganz kurz hier deren Advocacy zu betreiben, die haben natürlich auch ein, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, berechtigtes Interesse, aber es berührt natürlich ihr Geschäftsfeld sehr empfindlich und was du als Schlupfloch bezeichnest oder als unscharfe Definition kann, bei denen natürlich über Fortbestand oder Ende eines ganzen Geschäftszweiges entscheiden.
Also ein gutes Beispiel ist hier Instagram. Die wollten ja vor kurzem ihre allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen ändern und von Nutzern hochgeladene Bilder an Dritte weiterverkaufen. Und die hatten den Wahnsinn vorher angekündigt und dann nachher irgendwie einen Rückzieher gemacht, als es dann einen großen Aufschrei gab von Nutzern und in der Presse und Pipapo. Und hier in Brüssel lobbiedt die Industrie jetzt genau dafür, dass Daten einfach so ungefragt weiterverwendet und weiterverkauft werden.
Ja, man sieht zumindest, dass das frei hält. Meine Instagram ist da wahrscheinlich auch etwas, hat da auch wirklich schlecht kommuniziert, weil es ja auch üblich ist, sich in den allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen die Freiheit zu geben für diese ganzen Edge-Cases. Was ist, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie deinen Avatar oder dein Foto in einer Werbung abdrucke etc. Das muss ja dann auch explizit gestattet sein, dass wir nicht die Nutzer dann wiederum die Firma verklagen. Das sind, glaube ich, wenn man es ihnen jetzt mal gut anrechnet, auch die Motivationen gewesen. Aber es ist halt einfach alles sehr unklar, in welche Richtung es letzten Endes wirklich gehen kann. Kein Wunder, dass die sich da jetzt werben. Aber Instagram ist ja letztlich jetzt auch nur Facebook. War ja auch teuer genug.
Naja, ich meine, letztendlich haben sie die ja ganz billig bekommen. Die haben dir ja nur diese Facebook-Aktion gegeben. Die sind doch nichts mehr wert.
Naja, nur nicht.
Also von der Milliarde oder was, ist da jetzt nicht mehr so viel über.
Naja, ich glaube, die müssen jetzt nicht darben. Die müssen nicht Hunger leiden. Ja, wie sieht es denn bei euch aus mit der finanziellen Unterstützung von eDRI? Woraus ernährt sich eure Lobby-Tätigkeit?
Ja, wir kriegen ein paar Spenden, aber nicht viele. Wir ernähren uns hauptsächlich durch diverse, na wie nennt man das auf Deutsch, Foundations-Stiftungen, glaube ich. Also wir bekommen ein bisschen Geld von der Open Society Foundation und noch von einer anderen niederländischen Stiftung.
Aber doch auch von den Mitgliedern, oder nicht?
Ja, Mitgliedsbeiträge sind ziemlich gering. Also wenn du bei uns Beobachter werden willst, dann musst du 10 Euro im Jahr bezahlen und Mitglieder bezahlen 100 Euro im Jahr. Also das ist wirklich nicht viel.
Also betrifft das jetzt auch die Gruppen wie Fibodt etc.?
Genau.
Die zahlen auch nur in Hunni?
Das ist ja noch sehr überschaubar.
Hm, könnte man mal über eine Erhöhung nachdenken. Ich schaue gerade auf eurer Seite, ob es da irgendwie einen direkten, so einen Direktlink zum Spenden gibt?
Ja, oh Gott, unsere Internetseite muss auch neu gemacht werden, aber da sollte irgendwo links Donate stehen.
Da könnt ihr mal ein bisschen größeren Button drauf machen, dann funktioniert es vielleicht auch gleich besser.
Ja, könnte man überlegen. Ah ja, wie gesagt, also wir werden unsere Webseite bald neu machen und Edri befindet sich gerade auch im Wachstum. Das heißt, wir werden wahrscheinlich, wie Linus eben angeregt hat, die Mitgliedsbeiträge überarbeiten. Und wir bekommen demnächst noch ein paar Leute mehr hier ins Brüsseler Büro.
Das wäre noch das, was mich interessieren würde. Wie viele Vollzeitkräfte habt ihr da eigentlich? Also ich meine, ihr seid eine Sammlung von über 30 NGOs, für die letztendlich ihr da sitzt. Und meines Erachtens seid ihr auch so wirklich, wenn nicht die Einzigen, dann einer der wenigen Akteure, der in Brüssel da Advocacy betreibt für Bürgerrechte. Wie ist denn so die allgemeine Großlage? Wie viele Leute habt, also wie viele Mitstreiter habt ihr so bei Edri selber und überhaupt, also vielleicht einmal so das große politische, die große Wetterkarte in Brüssel aus eurer Sicht, würde mich noch interessieren.
Ja, also wir sind die einzigen, die hier irgendwie Netzpolitik machen und die sich für digitale Bürgerrechte einsetzen. Und ich glaube, die EFF hat in den USA, die haben irgendwie so 50 Leute und wir machen die Arbeit, die die EFF in den USA leistet, mit drei Leuten. Also bis vor kurzem, bis vor einem Jahr war Joe hier, Joe McNamee, ganz alleine und hat den Laden geschmissen und seit einem Jahr bin ich noch mit dabei und noch eine Kollegin. Also wir machen das zu dritt.
Für die digitale Bürgerrechte Europas. Während bei dieser Datenschutzreform jetzt, du sagst, dass so im Prinzip jede Firma, die sich da irgendwie angesprochen fühlt, jedes größte Unternehmen da allein schon mal ein, zwei Leute hinsendet.
Genau. Also wie gesagt, die Industrie, die hat hier in jedem Industriebereich mindestens einen Lobbyisten, der an dem Dossier arbeitet. Und das ist sogar, glaube ich, keine Ahnung, was gab es da letztens? Irgendwie Leute aus dem Schifffahrtsbereich, die arbeiten auch an dem Ding. Also das ist Wahnsinn.
Also wenn du sagst, das sind ganz viele, wie viele? Also schätz mal, sind das jetzt 10, 100 oder 1000? In welchem Bereich bewegt sich das jetzt?
Also wenn wir im Bereich der Urheberrechte arbeiten, dann schätzen wir, dass unsere Gegenseite so ungefähr 1000 Leute hat. Aber ich glaube ja, was die Datenschutzverordnung angeht, das weiß ich nicht.
Schlimmer oder nicht so schlimm?
Schlimmer, also ich weiß nicht, wie viele. Über 9000 wahrscheinlich. Ja, ich weiß nicht, also es gibt ja dieses Transparenzregister, wo sich alle Lobbyisten eintragen können, die irgendwie die EU-Kommission und das Europaparlament bearbeiten. Und ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute da drin stehen, keine Ahnung. Und dazu kommen nochmal ganz viele, die sich natürlich nicht ins Transparenzregister eintragen.
Das stützt meine These, dass ihr da durchaus nochmal ein, zwei Leute gebrauchen könntet.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das kommt jetzt im nächsten Jahr. Bekommen wir hoffentlich noch ein, zwei Leute dazu und dann...
Im nächsten Jahr, in diesem Jahr hoffen wir.
Ja, 2014 und 2015.
Also doch erst nächstes Jahr, okay. Das ist ja noch eine Weile hin. Na gut, was man vielleicht auch noch erwähnen sollte, ist, ihr habt so einen regelmäßigen Newsletter, das Edri Gramm. Das kann man sich abonnieren. Und ansonsten, wann ist eure Party?
Die Party ist am 2. März.
Am 2. März in eurem Büro?
Ja, hier in Brüssel.
Wie sich das bei Lobby-Organisationen dann gehört, mit Schnittchen und Pipapo?
Ne, ich hätte da gerne ein paar DJs. Also wenn ihr DJs kennt, die hier gerne in Brüssel auflegen würden, dann können die sich bei mir melden.
Alles klar, 2. Super Kirsten. Linus, haben wir noch was?
Wir haben noch was, aber die Kirsten müssen wir verabschieden. Die muss weiter lobbyieren.
Genau. Betreiben, viel sprechen. Genau. So, Linus, jetzt sind wir wieder alleine.
Wir machen mit nahtlosem Anschluss direkt weiter. Das ist echt Freunde der Podcast-Technik. Das war jetzt hier live. Das ist ungeschnitten und live.
Ja, roh.
Roh. So wird hier gearbeitet.
Qualitätspodcasting. Da brauchen wir mal, dass wir die Level jetzt auch halten können.
Ja, wir machen...
Mit dem Knallerthema weiter.
Knallerthema. Knallerthema. Übrigens, an der Stelle muss dann, vielleicht muss ich ganz kurz sagen, es sei uns dann verzieht, diesen ganzen Instagram-AGB-Wirbel, den haben wir einfach mal ignoriert. Beziehungsweise nicht ignoriert, aber es gab dann glaube ich keine...
Keinen Termin.
Keinen Sendungstermin.
Jetzt fallen wir in die Pause rein, ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass wir das so kurz übersprungen hätten. Ja, ich glaube, das war aber auch die Aufregung jetzt nicht so...
War die Aufregung nicht unbedingt wert. Was natürlich immer die Aufregung wert ist, ist, wenn die GEMA in die Schlagzeilen kommt. Zwar erinnern wir uns, ich habe festgestellt, dass ein Thema, das Logbuch Netzpolitik von Anfang bis Ende quasi behandelt, schon unsere zweite Sendung, glaube ich, handelte... Nee, Quatsch, das war das andere Thema. Okay, also es geht um den Streit zwischen GEMA und YouTube, der ja schon seit 2009 unterwegs ist.
Den wir ja auch schon mal fast eine ganze Sendung mit haben.
Die Sendung mit dem schönen Titel, du willst es doch auch. Ja, ich habe da gestern noch ein bisschen durchgeschaut. Und wir erinnern uns, da gab es das Urteil des Landgerichts Hamburg, das sagte, ja, YouTube ist ein File-Hoster. Das gestehen wir denen zu. Und kein Rundfunk. Aber als File-Hoster müssen sie natürlich auch mehr tun, um Dateien zu löschen, die da nicht hingehören. Das war so der Kern des Urteils in einem Satze. Gegen das dann nach wenigen Wochen GEMA, sowohl GEMA als auch YouTube, Berufung eingelegt haben, obwohl sie beide das Urteil nach seiner Bekanntgabe als ihren Erfolg gewertet haben. Aber es war ihnen natürlich klar, sie wollten irgendwie, es ließ noch zu viel offen, also hatten sie beide Berufung eingelegt und wurden aber dann auch von ihren jeweiligen Mitgliedern gedrängt, also der GEMA von ihren Mitgliedern gedrängt, die Verhandlungen da weiterzuführen und das jetzt nicht da weiter vor Gericht zu eskalieren, sondern sich an einen Tisch zu setzen und sich zusammen zu raufen und irgendwie eine Einigung zu finden, die zum Ergebnis hat, dass deutsche oder GEMA-vertretende Musiker auf YouTube gezeigt werden und YouTube den Zugang dort dazu nicht sperrt. Und jetzt erklärte die GEMA diese Verhandlung für gescheitert und möchte jetzt die Schiedsstelle beim Deutschen Patent- und Markenamt anrufen, um darüber zu entscheiden, welche Mindestvergütung für den Fall eines YouTube-Videos angemessen ist für die GEMA. Und natürlich will die GEMA auch Schadensersatz für die bisher nicht gezahlten Mindestvergütungen beziehungsweise den Verdienstausfall dadurch, dass YouTube die Bilder sperrt. Ich betone das ja immer wieder.
Verdienstausfall, das ist ja geil. Das heißt, jetzt wollen sie auch noch Geld dafür, dass etwas nicht gezeigt wird.
Ja.
Weil es hätte ja gezeigt werden können.
Es hätte ja gezeigt werden können. Sie hätten ja nur bezahlen müssen.
Ah, das ist ja meine geile Logik. Vielleicht sollte ich bei der ARD eine Rechnung schreiben. Also mein Verdienstausfall dafür, dass sie meine Podcasts immer noch nicht im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ausstrahlen und mir eine angemessene Tansie bezahlen. Der geht einfach mittlerweile in die Millionen. Und das kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Also es geht noch um was anderes. Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, weil ich das ganz spannend finde. Also die GEMA... Das war jetzt für mich das erste Mal, dass ich offiziell wirklich mal die Preise gehört habe. Es waren immer auf Diskussionsveranstaltungen, die ich dann besucht habe, war dann immer klar, es ist irgendwie hinter dem Komma-Cent-Bereich. Aber die Zahl ist, die GEMA verlangt 0,375 Cent pro Stream. Ja, etwas über ein Drittel Cent wollen die quasi pro...
Pro Stream, pro abgespieltes Filmchen.
Pro abgespieltes Filmchen haben. Und dann, was natürlich dann am Rande debattiert wird bei dieser Forderung, ist, wann ist das Filmchen abgespielt? Kann man da nicht diesen 0,375 Cent dann nochmal durch Abspieldauer teilen oder so? Das wären dann Randdebatten. Was YouTube allerdings möchte, ist eine Gewinnbeteiligung ausschüten. Das heißt, die sagen, wir zeigen diese Videos, wir haben da Werbung drin und wir können im Prinzip auf ein Video zurückführen, wie viel Geld wir damit gemacht haben. Dementsprechend möchten wir eine Gewinnbeteiligung an die GEMA ausschüten.
Was für sie insofern unkomplizierter ist, ist, dass die Kosten nicht beliebig skalieren können, sondern immer an die Einnahmen gekoppelt sind und von daher für sie immer einen Gewinn darstellen.
Das ist richtig, das Spannende.
Das setzt aber auch voraus, dass jedes Filmchen, wo GEMA Musik drin ist, auch Werbung trägt.
Genau, das setzt es natürlich voraus. Wenn YouTube jetzt sagt, wir zahlen euch 0,375 Cent pro Stream, dann würde ich natürlich als Künstler oder als GEMA mir ein paar Server aufstellen, die den ganzen Tag nur GEMA-Videos auf YouTube gucken. Das bringt mir ja dann Geld. Das heißt, das ist natürlich die Gefahr, die YouTube wittert, von der GEMA verarscht zu werden. Während die GEMA, wenn YouTube sagt, wir schicken euch eine Gewinnbeteiligung, natürlich vermuten muss, dass YouTube dann die GEMA bescheißt. Denn den Gewinn, den YouTube mit einem Video macht, kann man nicht so schön ablesen, wie auf der Webseite.
Das Problem besteht natürlich jetzt mit allen anderen Partnern, die sie jetzt schon haben, und diese Bot-Vermeidung ist natürlich auch Teil ihrer Systematik. Das kann man jetzt, glaube ich, der GEMA jetzt nicht so pauschal unterstellen, dass sie jetzt sofort, wenn sie einen Deal hat, anfängt, mit unlauteren Methoden die Kohle einzutreiben. Ich glaube, da sind sie schon...
Nein, so weit sind sie noch nicht. Ich glaube, die habe ich jetzt auch auf eine blöde Idee gebracht. Also ich meine, die GEMA, wie gesagt, das sind Leute, die haben eine kleine Website und mehr haben die nicht mit Computern. Und wenn die ausgeht, dann lassen sie 100 Leute verhaften. Also da muss man jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass sie das tun würden. Also ganz klar, da sind sie, denke ich, von jedem Verdacht erhaben. Aber das also ist jetzt hier der Streit. Und was ich ja schon mehrfach betont hatte, es ist also ein Streit. Und es ist quasi so, dass YouTube jederzeit sagen könnte, okay, wir zahlen der GEMA den verlangten Betrag pro ausgestrahltem Video und lassen diese Warn-Tafeln weg, diese Warn-Hinweise. Oder diese Sperr-Hinweise, die YouTube ja da hat. Und da für diese Informationstafelchen, die sagen, was ist der genaue Text, der da draufsteht, das müssen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz schauen, damit ich da jetzt nicht falsch zitiere. YouTube, ach, bin ich gerade in Deutschland? Ja, also das könnte man mal sehen. Was wäre jetzt mal ein GEMA-Lied? Was ist überhaupt ein GEMA-Lied? Modern Talking. Gangnam Style ist auch...
Gesperrt.
Hier, Modern Talking ist nicht gesperrt. Oder bin ich gerade wieder nicht in Deutschland?
Modern Talking ist nicht gesperrt. Warum das denn?
Weil die ihrer sozialen Verantwortung nicht gerecht werden.
Das ist schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Es ist ja nicht wirklich alles gesperrt. Ich meine, da wo wirklich das Sperren auch mal einen kulturellen Auftrag erfüllen würde, da wird dann nicht gesperrt. Das ist auch alles sehr...
Wie macht man das denn? Ich will jetzt was Gesperrtes sehen.
Bei mir ist sowieso alles gesperrt, weil er immer noch Flashplayer fragt.
Ich habe HTML5, das funktioniert. Dieses Video ist in Deutschland nicht verfügbar, weil es möglicherweise Musik enthält, für die die erforderlichen Musikrechte von der GEMA nicht eingeräumt wurden. So. So lautet der Text. Und ich hatte ja schon darauf hingewiesen, dass das so halb wahr ist.
Ja, darfst du das nochmal wiederholen?
Die GEMA räumt die Rechte ja schon ein. Sie möchte halt nur dafür so viel Geld haben, wie YouTube nicht bereit ist zu zahlen. Deswegen sendet die GEMA jetzt auch eine Abmahnung an YouTube und sagt, durch diesen eingeblendeten Text wird der falsche Eindruck entweckt, dass die GEMA die Lizenzierung von Musiknutzung kategorisch verweigern, sagt der Vorstandsvorsitzende der GEMA. Das ist aber natürlich genau nicht der Fall, sondern die GEMA will ja, dass YouTube ihre Videos zeigt, damit die GEMA da die Einnahmequelle hat. Deswegen Abmahnung. Und sollte dieser Abmahnung da nicht entsprochen werden, dann folgt natürlich logischerweise die Unterlassungsklage, die dann die GEMA gegen YouTube anstrengen wird, aufgrund dieser Warntafel-Hinweise. Oder Warntafel, ich weiß nicht, ich nenne das jetzt immer Warntafel. Dieser einen falschen Eindruck erweckenden Sperrmeldungen. Das heißt, es bleibt spannend.
Ja, also ich meine, das ist ein Sandkasten-Kampf, der sich da abspielt, wo ich auch ehrlich gesagt gar keine Lust mehr, aber da noch groß eine Aufmerksamkeit drauf zu lenken. In dem Zusammenhang möchte ich nochmal auf die C3S-Initiative hinweisen, die wir hier auch schon ein oder zwei Mal, glaube ich, aufgegriffen haben. Die sich jetzt auch nochmal neu in Erinnerung gebracht haben durch eine Zusammenfassung ihrer bisherigen Aktivitäten auf dem bereits erwähnten 29C3. Dort gibt es auch ein Video, wo man sich das irgendwie alles schön anschauen kann. Sie haben sich da viel Mühe gegeben, mal zusammenzufassen, was eigentlich so die juristischen Herausforderungen sind, vor denen dieses Projekt steht. Noch haben sie sich ja nicht gegründet. Das liegt im Wesentlichen daran, dass sie einerseits noch auf der Suche nach potenziellen Mitgliedern und Unterstützern sind, also Leuten, die sagen, ja, wenn es euch gibt, dann treten wir da ein. Würde ich übrigens glatt machen, wenn da Podcasting irgendwie eine Option wäre, habe ich noch nicht mit denen darüber gesprochen. Wäre auch mal ganz interessant zu sehen, ob es da in die Richtung geht. Aber ich befürchte bzw. erwarte, und das kann ja auch verstehen, dass man sich jetzt erstmal voll auf die Musiker konzentriert, weil das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal das, worum es im Wesentlichen geht. Könnte aber trotzdem sein, dass da nochmal eine Perspektive auch fürs Podcasting abfällt, wie auch immer. Also wenn sie genug Unterstützer haben und wenn sie vor allem die umfangreiche Satzung ausgearbeitet haben, was ich richtig verstanden habe, hast du den Vortrag auch gesehen, Linus?
Ich habe den leider nur kurz gesehen.
Okay, also wenn ich es jetzt richtig erinnere, ist das sozusagen gerade noch im Prozess, denn wie man sich vorstellen kann, ist das jetzt nicht so ganz einfach und dann am Ende, ich glaube, das ist dann auch das Patent- und Markenamt, ne? War das nicht so, dass die Zulassung übersieht? Oder wechselt das jetzt gerade, weil du das erwähnt hast? Wie auch immer. Also eine Behörde muss dann eben das absegnen und sagen, ja, ihr erfüllt alle Anforderungen. Ihr könnt auch glaubhaft machen, dass ihr die Gelder nicht nur einsammelt, sondern dass ihr auch dann den rechtmäßig zustehenden Menschen auch zukommen lasst und dass ihr entsprechende Rücklagen bildet, etc. Also dass man sozusagen alle Rahmendaten erfüllt, die eine Zulassung dann ermöglichen. Und wenn das dann in einer hoffentlich nahen Zukunft auch mal stattfindet, dann wird es halt spannend, weil dann nämlich die große GEMA-Vermutung einfach von heute auf morgen fällt. Das ist etwas, da kann man gar nicht oft genug darauf hinweisen. Also es geht bei der C3S jetzt nicht nur darum, ja, wenn ihr Creative Commons macht, dann seid ihr da vielleicht an der richtigen Stelle, sondern es geht grundsätzlich darum, überhaupt erst mal eine zweite Verwertungsgesellschaft für den Bereich Musik zu schaffen. Also für den Bereich zumindest, für den die GEMA sich selbst zuständig sieht. Und in dem Fall ist nämlich die Gesetzeslage bereits jetzt schon so, dass wenn es halt mehr als einer ist, dass denn diese Vermutung, die sogenannte GEMA-Vermutung ist nämlich in dem Sinne gar keine GEMA-Vermutung, sondern es ist sozusagen die Vermutung, da es nur einen gibt, kann das ja sozusagen nur dieser einen Organisation zugeschlagen werden. Und in dem Moment, wo es eben zwei gibt, entfällt das. Das heißt, die GEMA müsste automatisch eine andere Verhaltensweise an den Tag legen, in dem Moment, wo es eine zweite Organisation gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich dessen schon so bewusst sind. Ich vermute mal ja. Aber es gibt ja noch keinen aktiven Handlungsbedarf, da es ja diese Organisation noch nicht gibt. Und da ist hinter den Kulissen irgendwie versucht werden, schon Steine in den Weg zu schieben. Weiß ich nicht. Ich will jetzt hier keinem was Böses unterstellen. So oder so halte ich das C3S aber eben für ein unterstützungswürdiges Projekt. Und es macht auch so den Eindruck, als ob es da einige aufgeklärte Leute aus der Musikerlandschaft gibt, die eben sehr wohlbegriffen haben, dass das eine gute Idee ist und das eben auch entsprechend schon unterstützen. Was ist das zu dem Thema? Dann schreiten wir voran. Schule.
Schule, ja das ist nämlich das Thema, was wir von vorne bis hinten behandelt haben im Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Der Schultrojaner.
Schon in Folge 2 tauchte er auf und jetzt, wir hatten ja ihn schon bereits, glaube ich, in einer Folge schon erklärt, dass das jetzt, also der Schultrojaner auf jeden Fall schon mal vom Tisch ist als Trojaner. Wir erinnern uns, es ging dabei darum, in einem Rahmenvertrag zwischen Verlagen und den Lehrern, den Schulen, der Kultusministerien zu klären, wie Lehrer mit Lehrmaterial umzugehen haben. Also, wie dürfen sie digitale Kopien erstellen, wenn ja, in welchem Umfang. Und dann kam man eben auf die Idee, dass man doch auf bestimmten Rechnern ein Programm installieren könnte, was dann überwacht, ob sich dort irgendwie zu viele Kopien oder zu zu umfängliche Kopien von einem Lehrmaterial drauf befinden oder angefertigt werden. Das Team, das das Programm hätte schreiben müssen, hätte auch all meinen Mitleid gegolten. Naja, also das war die Idee.
Wir haben ja auch viel Mitleid für Leute, die sich sowas überhaupt erst einfallen lassen. Schon die Idee ist auf so vielen Ebenen kaputt, das geht gar nicht.
Wobei die Leute mitleidige ich weniger um die Idee, als um das, was diese Idee irgendwann mal genährt hat.
Ja, ihr Mangel an Durchblick, der macht mich einfach traurig. Also das ist schon ein bisschen schlimm. Aber da scheint sich das Blatt dann doch bei all dem Protest kräftig gewendet zu haben. Irgendwie ist es dann nachdem das mal etwas diskutiert wurde, dann jedem auch irgendwie klar geworden, dass das eine Schnapsidee ist. Und dass es, sagen wir mal, auch jenseits der Legalität auch einfach ein Mangel an Legitimität gibt für solche Aktivitäten. Und jetzt gab es eine neue Einigung, eine neue Vereinbarung zwischen dem Bundesverband der Lehrerinnen und Lehrer haben sich geeinigt, oder haben die das nur bekanntgegeben.
Sie haben, der Bundesverband der Lehrerinnen und Lehrer an beruflichen Schulen hat bei der Sitzung der Kultusministerkonferenz erfahren, dass es neu ausgehandelt wurde. Und zwar gibt es einen neuen geänderten Vertrag, den die Lehrerverbände in seiner Form so unterstützen. Und in diesem neuen Vertrag ist nicht mehr die Rede von Plagiatssoftware oder Kontrollen, sondern nur von Schätzungen durch die rechte Inhaber. Die neuen Regeln, wie also ein Lehrer mit Lehrmaterialien, die durch Schulbuchverlage bereitgestellt wurden, umgehen darf, um die kostbare Ressource Bildung auf seine Schüler und Schülerinnen zu verteilen, sehen also, wie folgt aus nach Paragraph 53 Urheberrechtsgesetz und so weiter, gibt es also einen Gesamtvertrag. Und die Lehrer dürfen jetzt bis zu 10 Prozent, maximal aber 20 Seiten eines urheberrechtlich geschützten Werkes einscannen. Und das gilt auch für Werke, die nach 2005 erschienen sind. Also liebe Lehrer, 10 Prozent eines urheberrechtlich geschützten Werkes, maximal aber 20 Seiten, dürft ihr einscannen.
Die nach 2005 erschienen sind?
Auch.
Achso, auch solche Werke?
Auch, das war vorher, gab es da vorher wohl eine Ausschlusspause für. Diese Kopien, diese Scans dürft ihr auf Datentriggern aller Art speichern. Ach, 80 Stück ist die Höchstanzahl, aber auf Datentriggern aller Art dürft ihr das speichern. Es gibt keine Einschränkung, welchen Datentrigger ihr nutzt, um eure Datei zu speichern, das ist auch schon mal gut.
Ich frage mich, auf was das sozusagen.
Ihr dürft sie im modernen Unterricht mit digitalen Medien nutzen.
Also kein althergebrachter Unterricht?
Nein, auch ein modernes mit digitalen Medien. Damit ist natürlich gemeint, das auf so eine Lernplattform wie Moodle oder so hochzuladen. Also nicht mehr zu sagen, ich lege jetzt meine 10% des Buches auf den Kopierer und lasse da irgendwie einen Baum durchrattern und gebe dann den Schülern das ganze Papier mit.
Ja, oder also iPads und so weiter.
Ja, sagen wir mal, gehen wir mal davon aus, Moodle, also iPad sehe ich jetzt noch nicht so viel an Schulen.
Also kommt auf die Schule an, mein Freund.
Kommt auf die Schule an, aber ist mir jetzt nicht allgemein bekannt, dass das jetzt schon sich wirklich durchgesetzt hätte. Gehen wir mal, sagen wir mal, also auf einer Lernplattform wie Moodle oder so, darf das dann bereitgestellt werden, dürfen die Texte auch selbst nutzen und an die eigenen Schülerinnen und Schüler weitergeben. Das ist sehr erfreulich, weil es zumindest mal eine klare Regelung gibt. Das mit diesen zehn Prozent ist natürlich interessant, weil auch das natürlich eine definierte Regel ist, die sich jetzt schwer forcieren lässt. Die Frage ist ja jetzt, sagen wir mal, es gibt ein Werk und ich bin ein Lehrer und ich habe unterschiedliche Klassen und ich möchte jetzt jeder einzelnen Klasse zehn Prozent zukommen, insgesamt zukommen lassen, aber insgesamt nutze ich 100 Prozent des Werkes. Ist das dann noch in Ordnung oder nicht?
Es ist total gaga, aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt ja auch einfach mal nur so auf dem Papier. Und ich meine, am Ende, der Punkt ist ja hier, es gibt jetzt keine aktive Überwachung. Erstens, weil es sowieso nicht funktionieren würde und zweitens, weil es einfach mal nicht geht. Und wenn jetzt einer da irgendwie 21 Seiten kopiert, dann wird er ja sicherlich jetzt nicht gleich der Computer explodieren. Ich halte es irgendwie für Quatsch und ich halte es gerade bei Lehrbuchmaterial für Quatsch, weil ich meine, Lehrbuchmaterial wird verkauft und wird hergestellt für die Benutzung in Schulen. Und jetzt sich da hinzustellen und zu sagen so, ach nee, ihr wollt das jetzt auch noch jemandem zur Verfügung stellen? Ja, Lehrbücher zur Verfügung stellen, das ist doch nur dazu da, dass es im Regal steht ungelesen. Ich finde das einfach weltfremd, dass man sich Lehrbuchverlag nennt, ein Lehrbuch verkauft, und dann darf dieses Lehrbuch auch nicht im Sinne des Unterrichts genutzt werden. Das ist einfach Quatsch. Ich meine, jetzt werden hier ein vergleichsweise überschaubarer Betrag von 9 Millionen Euro an den Verband der Bildungsmedien und die Verwertungsgesellschaften rückgeführt und da wieder irgendwie verteilt.
Moment. Nur für dieses Recht? 9 Millionen Euro?
Nicht für die Bücher, klar.
Nur für das Recht aus diesen Büchern dann nochmal...
Im Prinzip eine nachträgliche Preiserhöhung, um etwas sicherzustellen, was eigentlich ohnehin sein soll. Ich meine, an der Stelle haben wir wieder einfach das klassische Problem mit diesem krassen Urheberrecht, wo einfach kein Fair Use definiert ist in Deutschland. Und gäbe es das, und es würde eben Schulen etc. einfach mal mit einschließen, hurra, wäre die Sache geritzt.
Man muss jetzt mal sehen, also wie kommt es dazu? Du hast ja hier eine ähnliche Situation wie mit dieser GEMA. Du hast einfach einen Verband von Lehrmaterialienherstellern, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen den Status erlangt haben, von den gesamten Schulen respektiert zu werden. Es gibt, also auch Schulen haben bestimmte Vorgaben, was so als Lehrinhalt, zum Beispiel wenn man sagt, man möchte in der fünfte Klasse in Englisch unterrichten, dann gibt es eine grobe Vorgabe, was sie am Ende der fünften Klasse dann können sollen. Und diesen Ideen entsprechende Lehrbücher bauen dann natürlich die Lehrbuch-Verlage und bieten die zu horrenden Preisen an. Also Schulbücher sind alles andere als billig. Sie sind auch nicht ohne viel Aufwand herzustellen. Wenn wir in Richtung Universitäten gehen, nimmt das Ganze ja nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension an. Aber bleiben wir mal nur im Bereich der Schulen. Die Frage ist natürlich, mit wem diskutierst du da überhaupt? Du diskutierst damit Leuten, die seit vielen Jahrzehnten oder vielleicht auch über 100 Jahren genau davon profitieren, dass die Schulen und die Kultusministerien irgendwie jemanden brauchen, bei dem sie sagen, von dem bekomme ich Qualität. Es gibt natürlich auch den Gedanken der Open Educational Resources, nämlich einfach zu sagen, wir schreiben ein einziges Mal, gerade jetzt Mathematik oder so, ein einziges Mal ein Mathematikgymnasium, da hat sich seit Jahrzehnten nichts geändert, da gibt es keine neuen Entdeckungen mehr in der Mathematik, die jetzt, sage ich mal, auf dem gymnasialen Level große Rolle spielt.
Solange bis Primfaktoren-Zerlegung irgendwann nochmal ein Standard zu machen ist.
Genau, bis wir das dann irgendwann hinbekommen haben, ja. Das heißt, da kann man natürlich auch einfach einmal hingehen und das Lehrbuch-TM schreiben und das einfach unter eine Creative Commons-Lizenz legen.
Genau, oder Public Domain.
In die Public Domain geben und sagen, wupp, das ist es. Das ist es.
Das geht auch in vielen anderen Bereichen.
Das geht auch in vielen.
Das geht meiner Meinung nach eigentlich in allen Bereichen.
Das geht in allen Bereichen, die mitbilden.
Beschichte, tralala. Und ich meine, klar gibt es dann neue Erkenntnisse und da muss man natürlich auch kämpfen um die neuen Erkenntnisse, aber das ist ja dann bei den privaten Lehrbuchverlagen jetzt auch nicht anders.
Genau, was wird immer gemacht, wir leben in einem Gesellschaftssystem namens Kapitalismus, in dem das eine Ressource ist, der einfach ein gewisser Wert zugesprochen wird und dieser Wert dann auch von denjenigen, die ihn monetarisieren wollen, aufrechterhalten wird. Also Nestlé macht das ja an anderen Stellen mit Wasser, ist ja auch eine Ressource, die die Leute haben wollen. Das Problem ist, dass ja mit diesen ganzen offenen Sachen, man könnte ja auch zum Beispiel den Schülern erlauben, in der Wikipedia zu lesen. Also da lernen sie im Zweifelsfall schneller und lernen noch dazu, dass eine gewisse Kompetenz zum Umgang mit Medien dazugehört, weil ab und zu steht da doch mal Quatsch drin. Aber genau diese Furcht, dass da ja Quatsch drinstehen könnte, ist ja so tief verwurzelt, eigentlich auch in dem Denken, also insbesondere im deutschen Denken, dass die Lehrbuchverlage sich tatsächlich offensichtlich in der Situation sind, zu sagen, nur weil es Scanner gibt, wollen wir neun Millionen extra haben.
Also wir prangern das an, auch wenn wir jetzt zumindest schon mal hoderieren wollen, dass man hier überhaupt erst mal auf so eine halbwegs glütliche Einigung gekommen ist, auch wenn die grundsätzlichen Rahmenbedingungen, unter denen das jetzt entstehen muss, sind wir nicht so begeistert.
Die Rahmenbedingungen, es ist immer fürchterlich, wenn Bildung an Geld gebunden ist, egal in welchem Zusammenhang, wenn das, ob das jetzt die Länder betrifft, die dann gezwungen sind, da zu sparen, oder ob das Menschen betrifft, die eine gewisse Bildung bekommen möchten, das ist immer sehr, sehr schlecht aus vielen verschiedenen Perspektiven, nicht nur, weil es der soziale Ungerechtigkeit in sich birgt, sondern auch, denke ich, insgesamt als für das Fortkommen einer Gesellschaft, wenn Bildung an Geld gebunden ist. Und es ist immer besser, wenn dieses Wissen frei und offen ist. Und man sieht, dass Gesellschaften, in denen das der Fall ist, sehr viel besser funktionieren, sehr viel besser laufen, weniger Ungerechtigkeit haben, mehr Fortschritt erreichen. Und auch, denke ich, eigentlich ist es auch im Sinne des Kapitalismus als solcher, wenn die Bildung von ihm so weit wie möglich verschont bleibt.
So, weiter geht's.
Ja, ah, Facebook und der Datenschutz. Sehr schön.
Hatten wir doch schon heute.
Hatten wir heute schon, ja. Ich wollte dich trotzdem nur kurz mal behandeln. Und zwar geht es ja darum, dass das Telemediengesetz in Deutschland die pseudonyme Nutzungsmöglichkeit vorschreibt. Und daran hält sich ja Facebook mit seinem Sitz in Irland relativ offen, kunde ich nicht. Denn Facebook sperrt ja sogar aktiv Profile, wo die Leute nicht ihren richtigen Namen nutzen. Die haben ja auch irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen oder nee, vor ein paar Monaten schon irgendwie sowas gehabt, dass sie Leute, dass sie die Nutzer untereinander gefragt haben, sag mal, benutzt der seinen richtigen Namen da? Oder wie ist denn eigentlich der richtige Name von dieser Person? Das heißt, die haben sogar aktive Gegenmaßnahmen getroffen. Und wohl auch einige Profile, die dann als Pseudonym oder nicht unter richtigen Namen angemeldet wurden, gesperrt. Das war was, was Google Plus auch zum Anfang seiner Gründung gemacht hat. Die hatten auch diese Real Name Policy und da gab es auch einen riesigen Aufrüstung. Und das unabhängige Landeszentrum für den Datenschutz, Schleswig-Holstein, ULD, hat also dann so eine riesige Anordnung an Facebook geschickt, erstmal in die USA, dann wurde ihnen da gesagt, ey schickt ihn mal nach Irland und die werden da ja auch regelmäßig von Facebook vorgeführt. Kirsten hat ja gerade schon gesagt, warum die alle in Irland sitzen. Hat also jetzt diese Anordnung da hingeschrieben und sagt, sie verlangen also von Facebook, dass sie die pseudonyme Nutzung erlauben, zulassen und auch explizit darauf hinweisen, dass sie also da hinschreiben, sagen hallo willkommen bei Facebook, dort kannst du hier übrigens auch Pseudonym anmelden, und die Sperrungen von Pseudonym-Nutzerkonten aufhebt. Und dafür sonst, wenn das irgendwie in 14 Tagen innerhalb der Frist nicht umgesetzt wird, dann setzt das ULD ein Zwangsgeld in Höhe von 20.000 Euro.
Das wird natürlich Schockwellen auslösen bei Facebook.
Bei Facebook haben sie die Hände über dem Kopf zusammengeschlagen. 20.000 Euro, wo sollen wir die jetzt herholen?
Unsere Aktionäre verprügeln uns.
Haben wir irgendwie, gibt es da einen Schein für, haben wir einen 20.000 Euro Schein? Ansonsten müssen die uns ja Wechselgeld geben.
Ich glaube, das kratzt jetzt erstmal herzlich wenig.
Da lachen die sich Schrott drüber. Interessant waren dabei zwei Sachen. Also erstmal ist es natürlich krass zu sehen, wie völlig zahnloser Papiertiger diese Datenschutzbehörden sind.
Na gut, im Falle von Facebook vielleicht.
Im Falle von Facebook.
20.000 Euro würde ich jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres wegstecken, wenn man mir jetzt pseudonyme Nutzung hier...
Und interessant sind zwei Sachen. Und zwar weist dann der Thomas Stahler darauf hin, was ich sehr interessant fand.
Seines Zeichens Rechtsanwalt.
Seines Zeichens Rechtsanwalt. Und sagt, naja, was machen die Leute denn bei Facebook? Die machen da ihre Facebook-Seiten. Und die könnten in der Tat sogar einer Impressumspflicht unterliegen. Auch laut Telemedien-Gesetz, weil wir ja Impressumspflicht haben für Veröffentlichungen. Dann wiederum hätte Facebook nicht nur Grund dazu, sondern auch die Pflicht, die Leute bei ihrem Realnamen an den Hammelbeinen zu haben.
Wobei jetzt Impressumspflicht ja nicht erforderlich ist für reine private Blogs.
Ja, ich bin wie immer nicht so wirklich der Fachmann in diesem Bereich. Aber ich schaue mal ganz kurz, wie es der...
Es ist halt wieder mal das alte Ding mit Selbstständigkeit, Kommerzialität etc. Also wenn dir irgendwie im weitesten Sinne in irgendeiner Form eine Geschäftsgefühle, also ich kenne jetzt den korrekten Begriff nicht dafür, aber wenn dir sozusagen im weiteren Sinne irgendwie unterstellt werden kann, dass du mit deiner Webseitenpräsenz irgendwelche geschäftsmäßigen Ziele verfolgst, dann ist ein Impressum sehr angeraten, wenn nicht sogar nachvollziehbar Pflicht. Wenn es allerdings jetzt für dich so ein reiner privater Poesiealbum-Erguss ist, dann ist das nicht erforderlich. Also da ist die Rechtslage schon klar. Es gibt natürlich dann wiederum so Abmahnfreunde, die gerne dann alle gleich mal wieder mit irgendwelchen Abmahnungen überziehen, weil man ja sowas nicht hätte. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt wirklich jeder ein Impressum führen muss, sondern es hat schon was damit zu tun. Aber es geht natürlich dann schnell, wenn du irgendwie AdSense benutzt oder so, oder Flatterbuttons, dann kann man dir dann schnell unterstellen, dass du Einnahmeziele verfolgst und in dem Moment bist du dann sofort auf der kommerziellen, geschäftsmäßigen Schiene. Und dann greift das eben auch. Inwieweit man das jetzt auf Facebook anwenden kann, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe den Artikel jetzt von Thomas Stadler nicht gelesen, von daher wäre ich da auch interessiert.
Ich verweise da auf den Link, er zitiert dann die beiden Passagen des Telemediengesetzes. Ich würde da auch deine Zweifel so anbringen, aber interessant ist es auf jeden Fall, vor allem vor dem Hintergrund des berechtigten Interesses, was Kirsten uns ja da auch mal geschildert hat. Das heißt also, da sieht man...
Kann doch sein, dass das Telemediengesetz an der Stelle quasi den Datenschutz komplett aushebelt.
Weiterhin ganz lustig ist, wie bei TechCrunch dann darüber geschrieben wird. Also ich meine, es geht hier um Datenschutz gegenüber so einem riesigen Unternehmen, was da... Ja, da habe ich einen wunderschönen Artikel.
Das ist ja auch die fleischgewordene Merkbefreiheit.
Ja, aber es ist einfach sehr schön, weil man sieht, wie die USA dann darauf schauen. Wo also wirklich einer applaudiert, wie so ein Fußballer, der ein Tor geschossen hat und dann so sich das T-Shirt auszieht und Salto's macht. So ungefähr verhält sich dieser Autor bei TechCrunch, weil nämlich Facebook sich dagegen wehren wird und diese 26.000 Dollar, die das ja umgerechnet wären, nicht auf sich setzen lässt. Facebook wehrt sich dagegen und sagt also, wie schön Facebook dazu beiträgt, diese Anonymität, aus der die Menschen sich so asozial verhalten, aufzulösen und das Internet zu einem sichereren Ort zu machen. Das ist eine sehr interessante Argumentation, zu sehen, wie jemand, allen Ernst ist das so.
Es ist interessant, wie diese Pseudonym und Anonym in einem Artikel wirklich zusammenschweißen. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass jemand anonym das nutzt. Darum geht es nicht. Man kann ja Facebook sehr wohl sagen, wer man ist, aber man muss es ja nicht unbedingt gleich allen anderen sagen.
Mit der Anonymität kommt das Aufgeben der Verantwortlichkeit für seine Handlungen. Facebook-Nutzer können dann unter Hatespeech leiden und ihre Facebook-Erfahrung kann sich verschlechtern, wenn da Anonyme sind. Außerdem kann Facebook sich damit gegen Spammer wehren und hat eine legale Basis, diese Fake-Accounts endlich zu löschen. Unglaublich, wie er dann applaudiert. Gut, 26.000 Dollar ist wahrscheinlich ungefähr das Jahresgehalt dieses Autos da. Insofern sieht er da vielleicht echt einen wilden Kampf drin.
Aber so ist die Wahrnehmung manchmal. Da braucht man sich nur mal so ein paar Twitter-Timelines durchlesen, wenn mal wieder der Shitstorm of the day unterwegs ist. Insbesondere, wenn er sich um Feminismus oder sowas dreht, dann merkt man, dass Anonymität nicht die Voraussetzung dafür ist, dass so etwas passiert. Das wird durchaus auch von Leuten mit Realnamennennungen...
Es ist auch, unabhängig davon, Hate Speech zu verbieten, ist sowieso auch in den AGBs bei Facebook drin. Das heißt, wenn sich da jemand irgendwie wie Graf Rotz aufführt, dann kannst du dem auch den Account sperren. Da spielt das gar keine Rolle, ob das anonym ist oder nicht. Aber wie gesagt, sehr großer Unsinn, den diese Person da zusammengeschrieben hat, erwähnenswert.
Deswegen wird es ja auch auf dich kransch. Was haben wir denn noch?
Ja, auch eine ganz schöne Geschichte. Ein kurzer Aufmerksamkeitspeak nach Frankreich. Da gibt es den Provider Free. Die bieten also Internet für die Leute an. Das ist eigentlich eher der Prolo-Provider. Das ist ein sehr günstiger Provider. Die haben sehr billige Preise angeboten. Sie haben damit bis zu 5 Millionen User innerhalb kürzester Zeit in Frankreich bekommen, die zu ihnen gewechselt haben. Und die haben jetzt einen Firmware-Update im Dezember gepusht auf die Boxen, die sie bei den Leuten stehen haben. Die Freebox heißt sie dann nicht Fritzbox, sondern Freebox. Und mit diesem Firmware-Update wurde schon im Router Werbung blockiert. Das heißt, er hatte einfach, wenn ich das jetzt recht entsinne, einfach einen DNS-Server, der einfach bestimmte, bekannte Werbedomains nicht aufgelöst hat. Und das Feature war also ein Beta-Feature, was per Default in diesen Routern an war. Das heißt, sie haben den Nutzern geschenkt, dass Werbeanzeigen, dass sie keinen Adblocker mehr in ihren Browser installieren müssen, sondern einfach ein schöneres Internet mit weniger Werbung genießen können.
Zumindest mit weniger Werbung von Google.
Denn natürlich war dieser Werbeblocker, wie jeder Werbeblocker, nicht vollständig. Und das Problem ist außerdem, dass dieser Provider Free gehört zu einer Unternehmensgruppe, an der jemand signifikante Anteile hält, dem auch die Zeitung Le Monde gehört. Und es schien also so zu sein, dass unter Umständen dann Werbung von Le Monde durch diesen Filter nicht berührt ist. Das heißt, da gab es einen sehr kurzen Aufschrei von der gesamten Internetanzeigenwirtschaft, Verlegern, Anbietern von Internetplattformen und auch ein genaues Interesse von, sagen wir mal, Advokaten der Netzneutralität, was denn davon zu halten ist, wenn ein Provider so etwas den Leuten pusht. Wobei ich sagen muss, das Kritische hier ist dieses Default-Un, also das Feature als solches, ein Werbeblocker im Router, ist sicherlich nicht unbedingt verwerflich. Das Krasse ist natürlich immer das Default-Setting. Also wenn du das an 5 Millionen Kunden pusht, werden es nur sehr wenige sein, die es ausschalten. Gleichzeitig, wenn du es aus 5 Millionen Kunden zur Verfügung stellst, werden es verhältnismäßig wenige sein, die es anschalten. Die Neutralität des Netzes ist hier halt die Frage. Da geht es natürlich bis wo hin man die Neutralität dieses Netzes definiert. Das Netz als solches, bis zur Steckdose an der Wand bei den Leuten, blieb ja neutral und hätte diese Werbung ja auch ausgeliefert, wenn der Router sie angefragt hätte für seine angeschlossenen Heimnutzer. Interessanter Fall. Ich zitiere ihn deshalb, weil wir auch hier wieder etwas haben, wenn wir es jetzt mal als, nennen wir es mal, ein grau Bereich der Verletzung der Netzneutralität. Also es ist wie gesagt streitbar, ob es einer ist. Aber grundsätzlich irgendwas, was die Nutzer eigentlich freut. Also wir sperren dir Werbung, wir machen außerdem noch einen, haben wir noch einen Scanner auf Malware vielleicht draufliegen und so. Das sind alles Features, wo der Kunde nicht naheliegend unbedingt etwas dagegen haben müsste. Eher etwas, wo er sagen würde, ja, Mensch, das ist aber doch nett.
Ja, ich meine, die ganze Sache zeigt leider, dass wir wahrscheinlich demnächst einen neuen Problembereich auch bekommen, wenn wir ihn nicht uns schon längst eingetreten haben, nämlich der Router, der den Zugang zum DSL bietet. Gar nicht mal jetzt nur deswegen, sondern ich würde an der Stelle gleich noch eine zweite Meldung, die gestern kam, hier noch mit reinbringen. Und zwar hat die Bundesnetzagentur gesagt, dass sie keine rechtliche Handhabe dagegen sieht gegen die Kopplung eines Internetzugangs und den Einsatz eines bestimmten Routers. Das heißt, es wird jetzt sozusagen bestätigt, dass ein Provider, Ellis zum Beispiel, dir sehr wohl vorschreiben kann, dass du den von ihnen zur Verfügung gestellten Routers zu benutzen hast, weil dort die Zugangsdaten nämlich auch direkt drin abgelegt und nicht änderbar und eingebbar sind. Sprich, wenn du einen anderen Router anschließt, kann er sich gar nicht einloggen. Warum auch immer man sich bei seinem Provider an seinem eigenen Anschluss überhaupt einloggen muss, aber das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Diskussion. Faktisch erlaubt das jetzt an der Stelle eben genau solche Systeme dann auch zu etablieren, weil die Leute quasi in dem Moment, wo sie sich für den Vertrag entschieden haben, dann auch keine Möglichkeit haben, sich dagegen zu wehren und zu sagen, naja, wenn ihr mir hier nur Shit liefert, dann kauft man eine Fritz Box. Das wird damit eben verhindert. Also das halte ich auch für extrem streitbar, diese Entscheidung, und da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob wir nicht da einen neuen Quell von Unbild haben.
Ja, das kann schnell zum Problem werden. Das ist ein Problem.
Das ist ein Problem. Da bin ich auch dagegen. Ich prange das an.
Prange ich auch an.
Hart.
Hart prange ich das an. Das wieder mal die Auflösung, das Nichthalten an Standards, das wieder mal ein Login der Nutzer auf bestimmte Hardware. Und ich glaube, der Riesenerger war ja insbesondere diese Alice Boxen. Die haben ja auch Begrenzung gehabt, wie viele Nutzer sie in das WLAN lassen oder so, ne?
Ja, ich meine, es ist einfach vollkommen klar. Die haben Begrenzung in so vielen Hinsicht. Du kannst deinen DNS-Anbieter nicht mehr ändern. Damit öffnest du ja genau diesen ganzen Umleitungsfilter-Sachen Tür und Tor. Und wenn ihr jetzt halt auch noch Filter-Software direkt da einbauen, dann wird es wirklich super haarig. Vor allem, wenn dann diese Provider wiederum anfangen, irgendwelche Verträge mit irgendwelchen Anbietern zu schließen, also man kann sich das ja selbstbediebig weiterdenken und das macht keinen Spaß. Also Leute, geht nur zu Providern, wo euch nichts vorgeschrieben wird. Der Markt kann an der Stelle vielleicht zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch irgendwas regeln. So, haben wir das durch? Was haben wir denn noch?
Ich denke, was schon etwas älter ist, aber vielleicht für die interessierte Hörerin, die es noch nicht gelesen hat, war der Wunsch von Jonny Häusler, dass wir 2013 das Web zurückerobern.
Von wem jetzt?
Jonny Häusler, kennst du den?
Ja, den kenne ich. Aber von wem sollen wir es zurückerobern?
Von den zentralen Anbietern. Wir sollen uns wieder dezentralisieren und diversifizieren und aus dem Web wieder ein Web machen, ein Netz und nicht ein Kabel, was zu unserer Hauptplattform führt. Den Aufruf, das einfach mal zu lesen ist, gute Ideologieschulung, festigt die Ideologie. Den wollte ich noch als Lesempfehlung geben und außerdem wollen wir vielleicht noch kurz auf den 29C3 eingehen oder lassen wir das sein?
Können wir machen. Ich überlege jetzt gerade nochmal mit dem Web zurückerobern. Ich habe den Artikel leider noch nicht gelesen. Geht es im Wesentlichen jetzt um Facebook oder geht es darum, selber bloggen macht fett?
Also die Hauptthese ist Facebook, Twitter, Google, Tumblr, Apple, Instagram, Pinterest und wie sie alle heißen, sie machen das Web kaputt.
Apple auch.
Ja, also Apple denke ich kann man da auf jeden Fall benennen, weil sie ja durch diese Epifizierung im Prinzip schon fast das gesamte, also diesen Gedanken des Webs. Na ja, Web, muss ja wissen, Web ist ja nicht Internet, sondern Web ist ja World Wide Web. Also www.http.
Schön, dass du mir das jetzt nochmal so, dass du das jetzt fast verwechselst.
Und die meisten Apps nutzen HTTP ja hauptsächlich nur noch, um mit einer API zu kommunizieren. Und dagegen wendet er sich. Ich sage ja nur, dass man das mal.
Ja, da bin ich ja ganz anderer Meinung.
Okay, dann müssen wir das jetzt diskutieren. Dann müssen wir das diskutieren. Also sie sagen, was hier zum Beispiel, also wogegen er sich wendet, ist zum Beispiel Facebook im Rahmen seiner Login-Strategie, gibt dir sowieso schon mal keinen RSS-Feed und verhindert neuerdings auch das Reinpasen von RSS-Feeds aus Blocks. Das heißt, diese gesamte Syndizierung RSS und so weiter scheint da so ein bisschen ins Hintertreffen zu geraten. Und es geht, wir bewegen uns von einem dezentralen Web, sagen wir mal mit der Idee, was ein Block und was ein Ping-Bag ist, und Track-Bags und so.
Früher war alles besser.
Ne, das glaube ich so nicht unbedingt, aber wir bewegen uns aus einem dezentralen Netz, das auch dezentral genutzt wurde, hin zu einer Zentralisierung auf große Anbieter. Dagegen wendet sich Johnny in den Artikel.
Gut, das finde ich ja in Ordnung, aber ich finde nicht, dass UPS jetzt an der Stelle eine Rolle spielen. Also das halte ich für Quatsch. Also UPS sind an der Stelle überhaupt nicht das Problem, weil UPS letztlich nichts anderes sind als besser funktionierende Clients. Also das halte ich jetzt wirklich für Quatsch. Also du kannst UPS auch zum Einsatz bringen mit deiner eigenen Webseite. Und das ist an der Stelle wirklich Quatsch. Also das mit den APIs ist insofern interessant, als dass wir uns meiner Meinung nach jetzt schon im Prinzip auf einen API-War einstellen können.
Genau.
Das ist glaube ich ein Trend, der absehbar ist. Und diese Exklusions-Tendenzen, die wir jetzt hier schon an so vielen Stellen spüren und teilweise hier auch besprochen haben, machen sich in zunehmenden Maße über APIs deutlich. Aber es sind dabei an der Stelle nicht grundsätzlich ein Problem, solange sie sozusagen Standards implementieren.
Genau, sie sind nämlich eigentlich was Gutes.
Ja, dieses Ding ist natürlich, also die Abhängigkeit von Facebook und Twitter und anderen Großplattformen zur Kommunikation. Das ist halt etwas, wo die eigentliche Gefahr drin liegt. Und an der Stelle bin ich da auch ganz der Meinung von Johnny, so ist die Meinung, die er dort geäußert hat. Und man muss da sehr hellhörig sein, weil gerade APIs erlauben natürlich eine sehr viel feingliedigere Exklusion, als es bisher ist, durch diese Registrierungspflicht.
Wir müssen, glaube ich, mal erklären, was eine API ist.
Ja, das können wir auch tun. Wir setzen vielleicht zu viel voraus.
Genau, ich denke, wir sind da jetzt bei der Diskussion ein bisschen zu tief eingestiegen. Und zwar ist es ja so, also Twitter, nehmen wir mal Twitter als Beispiel, weil es ja gerade sowieso diese API-Debatte dort gab, ist ja erst mal eine Website und das heißt, die Server von Twitter stellen mir das, was Twitter macht, hauptsächlich über deren Webseite im HTML-Format da eine API ermöglicht ist. Er ermöglicht es dann als Application Programmer Interface in einer einheitlichen oder in einer definierten, standardisierten Sprache dagegen einen Client zu schreiben. Also mein Twitter Client auf dem iPhone spricht zwar HTTP mit Twitter, aber er lädt sich natürlich nicht die Webseite runter, um sie dann umzubauen und so aussehen zu lassen wie in dieser App, sondern er schreibt an die API, hallo ich bin Linus Neumann, hier ist mein Key und gib mir doch mal die letzten Tweets und jetzt möchte ich einen neuen schreiben und so weiter.
Oder ob es etwas einfacher zu formulieren, APIs sind einfach die Maschinenlesbare Kommunikation zwischen Webseiten und Programmen, während HTML im Wesentlichen halt eine human readable Version, also eine für Menschen gedachte Darstellung formuliert wird.
So und der Reiz von Twitter ist sicherlich enorm dadurch gestiegen, dass jeder irgendwie Clients dafür schreiben konnte. Jeder hatte auch seinen preferred Client. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Editor Wars inzwischen. Also Tim diskriminiert mich zum Beispiel. Jedes Mal, wenn ich Twitter gucke, Tim abschätze ich, weil ich einen werbefinanzierten Twitter Client habe. Aber das ist mein Client of choice und ich mag die Werbung auch da drin. Dann, nachdem ich jetzt dieses neue größere iPhone habe, habe ich auch mehr Platz. Das heißt, die Werbung nimmt nicht mehr so viel Raum und Twitter hat angefangen, das zu beschränken und hat gesagt, so Freunde, ab jetzt müsst ihr als App auch wiederum einen Key für die API haben.
Ja, das war schon immer so.
Genau, und den bekommt ihr aber nur unter der Bedingung, dass ihr euch an bestimmte Regeln haltet, was die Darstellung dieser Tweets angeht. Und ab einer gewissen Anzahl Nutzer sollten wir uns ohnehin mal unterhalten.
Ja, sie sagen einfach generell, wir wollen euch eigentlich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr. Vielen Dank, dass ihr unser Imperium mit aufgebaut habt. Vielen Dank, dass ihr auf so tolle Ideen gekommen seid, wie den Vogel als Logo zu benutzen oder das Wort Tweet. Haben alles Zart-Party-Entwickler erfunden. So, wir nehmen das jetzt einfach mal mit, aber ihr geht jetzt mal bitte, weil wir brauchen euch nicht mehr. Aber was ich noch viel schwieriger finde, ist, dass halt im Hin und Her zwischen den einzelnen Diensten, und das ist das, was ich als Apivore bezeichnen würde, eben jetzt auch so eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen Konkurrenzpartnern entsteht. Also Twitter und Instagram sind da das beste Beispiel, wie die jetzt sich gegenseitig davon abhalten, ihre Inhalte zu übernehmen, etc. Twitter reagiert auch schon seit Längerem sehr allergisch gegen Dienste, die eben auf Twitter einen Social Graph auslesen. Also schnell mal gucken, wem du so folgst, und dann darüber über andere Daten dann ein Matching im eigenen Netzwerk zu machen, um quasi den über Twitter einmal aufgebauten sozialen Graph wieder zu verwenden, was auch schon mal sehr interessant ist insofern, als das ja Twitter das sozusagen als Iris ansieht. Also dein Social Graph gehört ihnen, du darfst den nicht mehr mitnehmen. Auch sehr interessant, als ob die den aufgebaut hätten. Naja, und so weiter. Und ich denke, da wird sich einiges daran festmachen. Und wir werden uns auch auf kartellrechtlicher Ebene bestimmt bald mehr mit A-Peace beschäftigt sehen, als das derzeit noch der Fall ist.
So viel zu den A-Peace. Insgesamt geht es also in diesem Text von Johnny, aber glaube ich weniger darum, dass die A-Peace jetzt scheiße sind, sondern es geht einfach grundsätzlich um diesen Login, den sich die Nutzer im Prinzip unterwerfen, indem sie sich an einen Anbieter...
Na gut, aber ich meine, warum die Leute das machen, ist auch klar. Also das muss man auch ganz klar sehen. Die Software ist einfach zu kompliziert, sich selber einen Server aufzusetzen, ein eigenes Blog zu betreiben, das ist einfach ein Stress, den sich die meisten Leute gar nicht hingeben wollen.
Ich kritisiere es seit Jahren, dass die Nerds TM es nicht geschafft haben, ihre Lösungen so zu bauen, dass sie die Einstiegshürden besonders niedrig setzen. Man sieht das ja zum Beispiel mit Ubuntu, die es, denke ich mal, wirklich geschafft haben, Linux noch mal auf den Desktop zu drücken, als es eigentlich keiner mehr damit gerechnet hat, dass Linux sich noch mal nennenswert als Desktopbetriebssystem durchsetzt. Ubuntu ist hingegangen, hat es enorm geschafft, eigentlich aus dem Nichts, eine neue Linux-Distribution aus dem Boden gestampft, die eine enorm hohe Verbreitung gefunden hat. Gleichzeitig unterwirft sich Ubuntu selber jetzt auch mit diesem Ubuntu One oder so wieder, so Login- und Zentralisierungstendenzen, die da von der Community durchaus kritisch beäugt werden. Aber die Usability ist tatsächlich die Hauptschwierigkeit, die die Leute natürlich einfach zu einfachen Diensten treibt. Das heißt, die Nerds und die Hacker haben vernachlässigt seit Jahrzehnten sträflich den sogenannten dümmsten anzunehmenden User und unterstützen ihn einfach nicht. Das sieht man ja an allen Ecken und Enden, auch bei Software.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass es nicht so einfach ist.
Es ist überhaupt nicht einfach, ohne Frage nicht. Aber dieses Themenfeld, ich wollte es jetzt eigentlich nur kurz als Leseempfehlung geben, deswegen sind wir jetzt beide nicht so vorbereitet in die Debatte gegangen. Ich unterstütze grundsätzlich immer die dezentralere Lösung, so sie denn eine ernstzunehmende Alternative darstellt. Wir müssen leider in die Welt blicken und feststellen, dass wir keine konkurrenzfähigen, dezentralen Lösungen haben, die es mit Facebook aufnehmen können, die es mit Twitter aufnehmen können. Es gibt immer Ansätze dazu und die sind auch häufig von überraschend guter Qualität, aber sie sind den zentralistischen, kapitalistisch fundierten Originalprodukten in Sachen Usability häufig einfach enorm unterlegen.
Schöne Grüße von eurem antikapitalistischen Kampfpodcast, Logbuch Netzpolitik. Gut, lass uns zum Schluss nochmal kurz über den Kongress reden.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, auch so ein zentralistischer Podcast.
Ja, ja. Wir monopolisieren hier die Informationen.
Ich bin ja froh, dass wir noch unbezahlt. Also übrigens, eure Gedanken, was ihr denkt beim Hören von Logbuch Netzpolitik, gehört jetzt uns.
So, zumindest müssen wir uns jetzt fragen, wie wir daraus welche Konsequenzen ziehen wollen. Los, Kongress, bringen wir es zum Abschluss hier.
Ein hoher Lied auf Hamburg, natürlich war ich da. Großartig, es war unglaublich, ich fand es total spitze, ich bin völlig begeistert. Dieser Kongress ist nach Hamburg umgezogen, nicht ohne Grund schon zum 29 und nicht erst zu 30, weil natürlich die Befürchtung im Raume stand, dass man sich mit den Herausforderungen eines Umzugs, das 30-jährige Jubiläum des Kongresses ruinieren könnte.
Ja, das ist etwas weniger das Argument, der Hauptgrund ist natürlich, dass nächstes Jahr das Sommercamp in Holland stattfindet, wo viele sind und dann würde wirklich die Zeit fehlen. Das war auch die richtige Entscheidung.
So, und was ist, man fährt nach Hamburg, geht da rein und es ist einfach geil. Alles hat perfekt funktioniert, aus meiner Perspektive. Es waren einfach mal knapp 2.000, 3.000 Leute mehr dort von der Besucherzahl.
Also es hat sich gefühlt verdoppelt.
Gefühlt verdoppelt. Die Fläche allerdings hat sich wahrscheinlich verdreifacht oder vierfacht. Das heißt, insgesamt war es einfach ein bisschen luftiger. Man konnte wunderschöne stundenlange Spaziergänge auf dem CCH-Gelände machen, also überdachten Gelände. Und auf fünf Etagen einfach so viele Leute, die da Tische und Assemblies hatten, so viele Workshops, es war einfach eine unglaublich großartige Veranstaltung.
Ja, trotzdem hat man schon gemerkt, dass jetzt auch schon sich die nächsten Wachstumsschmerzen ankündigen. Ja, das Gebäude ist ja deutlich teurer für den Club. Also von daher war das Ganze dieses Mal auch finanziell ein großes Risiko. Man ist da, glaube ich, mit einem blauen Auge davongekommen. Aber das lief beileibe nicht so easy, wie das jetzt im BCC war. Das BCC war, sagen wir mal, ein finanzielles Risiko für den Club an der Stelle, wo man eben noch mit 2500 Leuten gerechnet hat. Also das Risiko, das war sozusagen, sagen wir mal, da wo das ganz gut gepasst hat, wo ja auch das Gebäude noch gut gepasst hat. Aber dann ist es eben so schnell angewachsen, dass dann eben sowohl das Gebäude geblutet hat, als eben auch die Veranstaltung als solche. Und nur finanziell war das dann eben nicht so ein Problem. Jetzt ist man ein deutlich größeres Risiko eingegangen und hat von daher ja auch auf die Nutzung von zwei möglichen großen Räumen noch verzichtet. Unter anderem eben dem Saal 2 und dem Saal 3. Ob es den Saal 3 gebraucht hätte, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Den Saal 2 wiederum, der immerhin so eine Kapazität von 1500 Leuten gehabt hätte, der hat gefehlt, weil man dann eben nur diesen Saal 4 und den Saal 6, die mit 1.700 oder 600 Plätzen ausgestattet waren und da gab es dann wieder diesen Kongresseffekt. Das war tatsächlich überlaufende Veranstaltung. Das ist ja eigentlich das, was man jetzt ganz gerne weg hätte. Ich denke, man wird Mittel und Wege finden, diesen großen Saal 2 mit hineinzunehmen, was dann eben auch noch mal ein paar Änderungen in dem gesamten Betriebsablauf mit sich bringt. Eigentlich war diese nette Bar da oben zum Beispiel nur möglich, weil dieser Saal gesperrt war. Also das muss man dann sehen. Aber insgesamt ist da einfach so viel Raum und so viel Gestaltungsspielraum, dass ich da sehr zuversichtlich bin, dass der 30. Kongress noch deutlich besser besucht wird und sogar noch insgesamt noch mal ein bisschen toller rüberkommt. Denn was ich gemerkt habe und ich habe bisher überhaupt nur einen Kongress miterlebt, auf dem eine ähnliche Atmosphäre geherrscht hat. Und ich habe schon einige miterlebt. Also das, woran es mich erinnert hat auf vielen Ebenen war der 1. Kongress 98 im Haus am Kölnischen Park, also als der als Hamburg verlassen wurde sozusagen. Also der Wechsel von Hamburg nach Berlin in dieses größere Gebäude, wo ja auch so ein großer Konferenzraum war, nicht wahr? Also so ähnlich episch wie jetzt dieser Saal 1 mit 3000 Sitzen war im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die Kapazität von dem Saal war. Ich glaube, das war bestenfalls, der war nicht so groß, wie viele Leute mit ihm da reingepasst haben, 800, ich weiß es gar nicht. Was dann eben aber für den damaligen Füllstand des Kongresses genauso ausreichend war, ja und dann auch so mit so schönen orange Sitzen und damals noch großes Feature vom Haus am Kölnischen Park. Jeder Platz hatte noch einen eigenen Ausklapp-Tisch, was ja leider im CCH so nicht der Fall ist. Da muss man den Laptop noch auf dem Schoß haben.
Du konntest ja immer die Sitzreihe, ich glaube jede zweite Sitzreihe konnte es so umklappen.
Das hätte man machen können, da ist auch schon mal drüber nachgedacht worden, ob man denn das tut, aber man wusste halt nicht, wie die Nachfrage ist. Man hat jetzt schon gesehen, die 3000 Plätze waren dann eben auch bei manchen Veranstaltungen voll. Also bei den großen populären Sachen, es war voll. Man hat wirklich einen 3000-Sitz-Plätze-Raum gefüllt. Das ist total mind-boggling, wenn man da nur drüber nachdenkt. Eine Veranstaltung, die vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht so viele Teilnehmer hatte, schafft es jetzt für einen einzigen Vortrag so viel zu versammeln. Damals war das auch so dieses große Fragezeichen, oh Gott, wenn wir jetzt in so große Räume ziehen, in so ein großes Kongressgebäude, skaliert der Kongress mit? Ist das dann noch die Veranstaltung, die wir haben wollten?
Und sie ist es sowas von geblieben, sie ist es eigentlich erst richtig geworden.
Ja, jetzt wieder, aber auch genau denselben Effekt konnte ich feststellen damals, als wenn ich ins Haus am Königischen Park gegangen bin, wo auch die Skeptiker eine halbe Stunde rumliefen und feststellten, es ist alles prima, also es gibt genug Leute. Und auch dieses Mal musste man feststellen, weil das ist ja so eine Befürchtung gewesen, mein Gott, 7000 Leute, gibt es denn überhaupt genug von uns? Gibt es denn überhaupt genug von Leuten mit diesem Mindset, dass das da noch ist? Oder sind wir dann irgendeinem Mainstream oder Touristenstrom erlegen? Und die Wahrheit war einfach, und das war am ersten Tag sofort klar, ja, es gibt genug. Es ist immer noch genauso kuschelig, es ist immer noch genauso gemütlich, obwohl es so viel größer geworden ist, war die Gemütlichkeit noch viel intensiver als vorher schon.
Sie war viel intensiver. Beim BCC konntest du das, also BCC war, fand ich immer durchaus auch wirklich sehr stressig, weil es war einfach überall, schlug so diese Unruhe auf dich ein. Es ist so, selbst wenn du mal draußen warst, irgendwie ein bisschen, oder oben im ersten Stock, da war es dann immer noch am ruhigsten, da rannten auch die ganze Zeit Leute an dir vorbei. Und auf diesem, einfach aufgrund des Platzmangels, wurden sie da so rumgepresst. Und im CCH war es häufig einfach so, ach komm, wir gehen noch mal ein Ründchen, und dann einfach mal ist man wirklich da auch so durchgelaufen. Und selbst wenn man, selbst dieser 3000-Personen-Raum hat sich ja ohne großartige Schlangen oder Drängelei einfach gefüllt. Weil der auch 100 Türen hat oder so.
Da Zugänge über vier Etagen.
Ja, aber es war wirklich toll und ich bin mit keiner großen Erwartung hingefahren, kam rein und dachte, boah ist das geil. Und wir haben glaube ich bis zum zweiten Tag, wenn ich ehrlich bin, hatte ich bis zum Ende keine verlässliche Mental Map in meinem Kopf, die jetzt dieses Gebäude adäquat repräsentiert hätte. Ich habe da noch mit Erdgeist drüber gesprochen, der hat irgendwie die grafische Aufbereitung des Gebäudes, der Gebäudekarte gemacht und der schüttelte auch nur mit dem Kopf. Also es war supergeil, da wirklich einfach sich mal so ein bisschen zu verlaufen und selbst auch am letzten Tag irgendwie Ecken zu entdecken und zu sagen, ach Mensch, guck mal, was habt ihr denn hier gemacht. Also echt wirklich super.
Ja, jetzt muss man irgendwie mal so ein Quake-Level machen, damit man dann das Gebäude auch in- und auswendig lernt. Ich meine, das ist doch schon absurd. Hättet ihr euch jemals träumen lassen, auf ein Kongress zu kommen, wo man von dem einen Raum in den anderen Raum mit einer Rolltreppe fährt? Das war wirklich irre. Also ich hab's jetzt schon in zwei anderen Podcasts gesagt, ich wiederhole mich. Ich fand das wirklich herausragend, was dort organisatorisch geleistet wurde. Und vor allem war es eigentlich auch ein Siegeszug dieses Selbstorganisationskonzeptes, das sich hier in den letzten Jahrzehnten so entwickelt hat. Also dass das immer noch geht, so eine Veranstaltung, die auch in ihrer technischen Komplexität sich auch wirklich vor nichts verstecken muss.
Was heißt vor nichts verstecken? Die setzt Maßstäbe.
Genau, soweit geht es nämlich eigentlich. Also was da alles funktioniert hat. Alle deutschen Vorträge wurden live synchronisiert. Das muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen. Und das alles mit Freiwilligen.
Synchronisiert wäre übertrieben, simultan übersetzt.
Das meinte ich, Entschuldigung.
Lippensynchron, das wäre jetzt noch die Sahne. Live synchronisiert, okay, das möchte ich nächstes Jahr sehen.
Siehst du, es gibt noch Herausforderungen. Da geht noch was. Alle Witze müssen irgendwie eins zu eins in ihrem Humor übertragen werden. Ja, aber das ist auch, sagen wir mal, die Gelegenheit für Leute, die Sprachstudieren und ohnehin etwas Nerd-affin sind. Ich glaube, für die ist das eine super Gelegenheit, da einfach mal auch sein Können zu testen. Und ich habe ein paar Übersetzungen reingehört. Das war stellenweise wirklich gut. Das war an sich gut, und stellenweise war es beeindruckend. Sicherlich mag es da auch schlechtere Beispiele gegeben haben, aber überhaupt diese Initiative zu haben, dass eine Selbstverständlichkeit zugänglich machen. Da haben wir ja auch eben gerade in einem anderen Kontext darüber gesprochen. Die Nerds machen sich nicht zugänglich. Hier geschieht das, hier projizieren wir sogar die deutschen Inhalte, die bisher sehr unter uns blieben, in eine weitere Öffentlichkeit hinaus. Wir ermöglichen auch Leuten die Teilnahme an einer deutschen Diskussion, die in diesem ganzen Umfeld nicht uninteressant ist. Allein schon deshalb, weil sich durch den Club und den Kongress im Besonderen über die Jahrzehnte hier eine ganz andere Hackerkultur herausgebildet hat, wo die anderen ja auch so ein bisschen, die anderen im Sinne von allen anderen Ländern, vor allem auch die USA, aus diesen ganz fernen Blicken, die ja eigentlich mit der Schock standen, noch vor wenigen Jahren, als sie dieses Treibens hier gewahr wurden und sich gefragt haben, wie, da sitzen die alle auf der grünen Wiese, haben Spaß und die Polizei kommt zufällig mal vorbei, weil sie gerade noch Currywurst essen wollte und wusste gar nichts von der Veranstaltung. So, oder hier im Kongress, da sitzen die da irgendwie im BCC im Glashaus und während die Polizisten sich draußen auf der Straße drum kümmern, Hütchenspielein zusammen, wird da irgendwie im Flug gekifft. Das haben die einfach nicht...
Und irgendwie präsentiert, wie einfach mal komplette Scherzarchitektur auseinandergenommen wird.
Ja, genau, während die Veranstaltung rauf und runter in Tagesschau und Tagesthemen diskutiert wird, das war für die einfach ein Schock. Und dann auch noch dieses kulturelle Element der Hacker-Spaces kam dann noch hinzu. Und mittlerweile ist das ja ein Exportschlager. Und jetzt gibt man sozusagen auch noch die Möglichkeit, diese spezifisch deutsche Diskussionsnummer, ich will das jetzt nicht zu sehr überhöhen, weil who knows, wer dazuhört, aber es geht und es wird Folgen haben.
Ich würde noch was ganz anderes gerne hier auch noch betonen. Es gibt Menschen, es gibt natürlich immer und dieses Jahr natürlich ganz besonders viele Menschen, die zum ersten Mal zu diesem Kongress gehen. Und die, mit einigen habe ich gesprochen und viele haben auch über ihre Erfahrungen dann mal einen Blog-Artikel geschrieben oder so, die zum ersten Mal dahin gehen und die durchaus so was wie Berührungsängste hatten. Die also sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob ich willkommen bin, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da die Vorträge verstehe, ob ich da überhaupt mit Leuten ins Gespräch komme, ob ich da mit Leuten ins Gespräch, das ganz klassische, das Eintauchen in eine, da sind doch die Hacker. Und eigentlich durchweg habe ich von diesen Menschen unglaublich positive Erfahrungen berichtet bekommen, die also völlig begeistert waren, wie offen man auf diesem Kongress von allen willkommen geheißen wird.
Ja, gerade in dem Zusammenhang kann ich nochmal auf die Wikigeeks Spezialsendungen 6 zu 29C3 verweisen, eine Serie von Interviews, da komme ich am Ende auch nochmal zu Wort, aber deswegen will ich darauf nicht hinweisen, sondern weil da gerade ganz am Anfang ein erster Teilnehmer interviewt wird, der so von seinen Erfahrungen dort berichtet und eben auch genau meinte, naja, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich hier überhaupt mit jemandem ins Gespräch kommen werde und ging so davon aus, dass er erst mal zwei Tage mit allem warm werden musste, aber es dann irgendwie noch nicht mal über die Lobby hinaus geschafft hat, nachdem er draußen war, weil er einfach sofort in einer Gruppe von Leuten ins Gespräch kam und am Ende glaube ich auch noch meinte, dass irgendwie die Zahl von Leuten, mit denen er Ich hab mich ja gedenkt, zukünftig weiterhin in Verbindung zu bleiben, wie schon irgendwas Zweistelliges genannt hat. Da war ich dann doch schon sehr überrascht. Also gut, mag jetzt auch ein sehr kommunikativer Charakter gewesen sein, aber ich denke, dass es jetzt keine Ausnahme gewesen war. Das war tatsächlich etwas, was ich auch von einigen gehört habe. Und ich muss auch sagen, also unter den Bedingungen, ich kann aber nicht nur Fan werden.
Wird dann noch bemängeln auf der technischen Seite, was mir, also da, wenn du schon den Wiki-Geeks, wenn du das Wiki-Geeks spezial ansprichst, da hat dir sicher dann auch Michael Seemann ein bisschen beklagt über mangelnde technischen Fokus der Beiträge. Da bin ich aber, also da war ich zugegeben auch etwas enttäuscht. Ich gehe da ja auch als, oder ich gehe eigentlich hauptsächlich zum Kongress. Wobei du das jetzt konkret enttäuscht? Es war, es fehlte einfach so das große technische Ding, also so der, da war, also der technische Anteil hat mich da nicht so überzeugt wie in den Jahren zuvor.
Da war aber ein paar Klopper dabei, also kann man jetzt nicht sagen, dass das keine Highlights hatte.
Was denn jetzt zum Beispiel? Das war der beste Vortrag offensichtlich, das war ziemlich offensichtlich der beste Vortrag von NQE. Der ist auch dafür bekannt, die besten Vorträge zu machen, das war aber bei weitem nicht seine beste Leistung, also technischer Seite, ja. Da müssen wir jetzt vielleicht hier nicht diskutieren.
Ja gut, aber das war ein schönes Beispiel, es gab da auch noch andere Dinge, dann hier so Primfaktoren, Analysen, da sind durchaus schon gute Sachen gelaufen. Ich stimme dir aber an einer Stelle zu und ich denke, das ist jetzt auch etwas, wo der Club auch nochmal neu darüber diskutieren muss und das ist wieder eine interessante Parallele, weil als wir ins BCC gegangen sind, also diesen dritten Schritt gemacht hatten, 20C3, da war das irgendwie auch so, man merkte so, ja hier, neues Gebäude, geht schon irgendwie, gibt noch Probleme, das lief damals nicht ganz so seidig, weil das eben unmittelbar nach dem Camp war auch und es wurde dann aber sofort klar, irgendwie passt das ganze Veranstaltungsprogramm nicht mehr, da muss einfach eine Evolution stattfinden. Die fand dann statt, 21C3, wo man sich da neu aufgestellt hat. Ich denke, es wird jetzt einfach noch wichtiger, ein Modell zu finden für die Vortragsplanung, bei dem möglichst viele eingebunden werden, die da auch wirklich nennenswert was zu beitragen können. Also die Last der Vortragsauswahl ist auf zu wenig Schultern verteilt, beziehungsweise man hat noch nicht die richtigen Werkzeuge, um das zu machen. Aber da bin ich ehrlich gesagt recht zuversichtlich, dass man da auch Fortschritte macht.
Ich sehe da jetzt alles andere als ein Problem. Ich freue mich viel mehr auf den Kongress nächstes Jahr, wo dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder mehr in der Hinsicht kommt. Also ich bin jetzt, wie gesagt, weiter von entfernt, mich irgendwie zu beklagen.
Insofern blicken wir 2013 auch auf eine interessante Zahl von nerding-Veranstaltungen, weil ich habe es ja schon am Rande erwähnt, die OM 2013 ist angekündigt worden auf dem Kongress. Observe Hack Make, wieder mal so eine drei Buchstaben-Abkürzung, so wie es in Holland halt immer die Regel ist, immer alles mit einem neuen TLA zu benennen, von Mal zu Mal. Ist ja der CCC ein anderes Prinzip, beim CCC heißt immer alles CCC. Da muss ich sagen, haben die Holländer in gewisser Hinsicht einen anderen kreativen Freiraum entwickelt, der eigentlich beneidenswert ist. Also Observe Hack Make OM 2013, 31. Juli bis zum 4. August. Also wieder diese magische 1. Augustwoche, die dort genommen wird. Und wieder ein neuer Veranstaltungsort. Also bisher hat ja keine holländische Veranstaltung zweimal am selben Ort stattgefunden. Das fand ich auch sehr interessant. Leider habe ich die letzte verpasst. Warst du da eigentlich? Nee. Das war der erste Hacker-Event seit 1993, an dem ich nicht teilnehmen konnte. Das habe ich schon ein bisschen getrocknet.
Also ich werde auf jeden Fall zu Omen und freue mich dann da zu sein. Jetzt schon.
Genau.
Aber jetzt haben wir ja, also Tim, jetzt müssen wir wirklich, ich meine, wir haben jetzt, ich habe das ja gerade schon jetzt, den Mangel an Tech-Talks ja nur reingebracht, damit wir jetzt hier von unserer Jubel, die Jubelhacker, den Kongress hier nicht bis in den, machen wir uns auch unglaubwürdig, wenn wir jetzt hier weiter einfach nur noch schwadronieren, wie geil die ganzen Hacker-Veranstaltungen sind. Also wir müssen jetzt die Sendung, denke ich, einfach mal beenden. Ich finde, ja, also das, ja, wir müssen das an dieser Stelle jetzt, wir unterbrechen unsere Sendung für eine Beendung.
Das machen wir. Das machen wir. Du hast ja recht, aber die Veranstaltung war trotzdem gut.
Die Veranstaltung war großartig und, ja, tschüss.
Mal gucken, vielleicht war diese Sendung ja hier auch großartig. Wir starten ja auf jeden Fall mit Energie ins neue Jahr und freuen uns, dass ihr auch das nächste Mal wieder dabei seid.